>> Male presenter:
[Indian accent]
administrator and political activist, and
columnist. He was former Public Administrator.
Some of his achievements as Administrators,
as Administrator include: the rehabilitation
of 8,000 families in Vizag, who are displaced
by the Steel Plant, and large scale irrigation
projects like a two lakh acre dry land, irrigation
in Prakasham district.
Later, he resigned from IAS and, si-, and
has, since then has been leading the Lok-Satta
Movement, organized corruption and world politics.
Under his able leadership, Lok-Satta played
a prominent role in achieving electoral reforms
and the Right to Information Act and several
other reforms. But, he, Dr. Jayaprarakash
Narayan is presently a member of Andhra Pradesh
Legislative Assembly and his party has branches
in five states, and contested in three states.
And he also had, he also coordinates with
several reformist organizations, like Federal
Democratic [inaudible] India and People for
Lok-Satta.
As part of Pe-, People for Lok-Satta Rejuvenate
campaign, he's presently touring several citi-,
several cities in inter-, in the United States
and advocating some of the chok-, solutions
to the challenges India facing, like proportional
representation, local government allowing
NRI's voting rights and NRI's role in Indian
politics.
Thanks JP garu for making time in his busy
schedule and thank Innovation Team for making
this happen. Without no further delay, I invite
Dr. Jayaprakash Narayan. Sorry for inter [inaudible].
[applause]
>>JP:
[Indian accent]
Friends, I'm delighted to be here with you.
Oftentimes, when somebody is very tall, there's
a natural advantage in life. For once, I found
that [presenter] being very tall was a disadvantage.
The microphone was a little, at a lower level
and I was amused by this idea that what appears
to be of great advantage sometimes could actually
be a problem on occasion.
I think that's important when we discover
things about a society, about a nation, about
an economy, and in many ways about many organizations.
I was asked to make a few points about Indian
economy and politics and I've chosen the theme:
19th-century Politics and 21st-century Economy.
Can they coexist and if there are some serious
issues here, what can we do to make things
better?
If the 20th century offered us any lessons,
it is that you cannot delink economics from
politics. The biggest question decided by
the 20th century will allow us whether or
not the socialist economy was right or the
market economy was right. It's a central political
question.
Ultimately, we recognize that the economic
growth of a country is not neutral to the
political trajectory of that nation. And in
1991, when the Berlin Wall collapsed, in '89
when the Berlin Wall collapsed, in '91 when
The Soviet Union collapsed and much of the
world embraced market economy, but with certain
changes; certain significant changes. Then,
the assumption of the world is that humankind
has discovered what works best in terms of
economic growth and political organization.
But, I think we all should recognize that's
not an unadulterated victory of market economy.
The market economy won because they have actually
absorbed some of the socialist principles.
In the first half of the 20th century, education
and healthcare were not regarded as government's
business. But, in the second half of the 20th
century, most every major country in the world
of any consequence embraced both education
and healthcare as part of governments business.
The services may be provided by the private
sector, but it must be driven by the public
sector; just a broader understanding. In a
many-, very fundamental sense, it is this
synthesis of some of the socialist principles
with a market economy that made a success
of market economy possible.
Therefore, I would like to start off my presentation
with a brief discussion of the role of state.
What is it that the modern state should be
doing? It should be debating whether it should
be socialist or market based. What is the
role of the state? In India, this question
has never been adequately addressed. I would
like to argue that the state is primarily
meant for public order, justice, and rule
of law; apart from the difference of the [inaudible
] so on and so forth. And then it must be
essentially to enhance the capabilities of
the citizens of the societies--
[phone rings]
of the society, so that the accident of birth,
"accident of the womb", as Warren Buffet called
it, does not determine the fate of the child.
And that is education and healthcare. And
then, of course, infrastructure required for
a modern economy, in particular, transport
and powers technical, communications, thanks
to all of you guys; the government's role
is now very marginal except minimal regulation,
really. And the natural resources development
there's no way anybody but a straight actor
is going to do something like Tennessee Valley
Authority, or the Hoover Dam. It has to be
a governments business. And finally, social
security, a measure of social security so
that those who fall into the cracks, their
concerns can be addressed in a humane modern
society. Once we look at state and its role
with greater clarity in this manner, I think
a lot of questions can be addressed much better.
The economic story of India, in the past 10,
15, 20 years, is by now reasonably well understood
across the world. In 1947, we start with 2%
to the global GDP. There is something called
global GDP. But, not too long ago in human
history terms, about three centuries, four
centuries before that, India shape of economic,
the world economy was something like 25%.
But all until 150 to 200 years because we
did not even take advantage of the Industrial
Revolution. India fell to 2% of the global
GDP. By 1991, this fell down to 1% of the
GDP. The economy in India grew at a snail's
pace, but in terms of the global economy,
our share came down to 1%. In 1991, as we
all know now, the current Prime Minister as
Finance Minister of India, in the wake of
an enormous crisis, out of compulsion, not
conviction, engineered and made a U-turn in
our economic policies.
Today, we are back at 2% of the global GDP.
In other words, we ran very hard for 63 years
to remain where we were. In related terms,
not that India hasn't progressed at all, but
we're still the way we were in 1947. But,
the general perception is with a reasonably
good growth rates, those cannot matching China's,
and with some everyday stuff, sustaining those
growth rates, India could well be one of the
major economies of the world in the next few
decades.
The emerging markets forum say it's by 2039.
If India does a few things right, we could
well be the second largest economy in the
world. That China will be the largest is more
or less accepted now, I think. There are a
very few people in the world who say that
anything else is possible now. But the future,
of course, may tell us a different story.
Whether India will actually fulfill our potential
is a great challenge. My argument is India
has the potential to achieve this miracle,
but we are to make this miracle happen. Our
politics has become now a great impediment
to economic growth and to fulfilling India's
potential.
[pause]
If you look at politics of India in the past
60 years, there's a huge success story. At
one level, India is the first country in the
world to embrace universal adult franchise
on the first day that the Constitution was
written. For largely illiterate and extremely
poor country, to embrace adult franchise on
a universal basis from day one was actually
a great adventure. It was an enormous expression
of faith in the wisdom of the bulk of the
people of the country.
This very great country in which we are right
now: the first republic in the modern world,
the first democracy in the modern world, the
first country to practice abolition of powers,
the first country with a written constitution,
despite recognition that all human beings
are equal, it took them something like, 144
years after those immortal words written in
The Declaration of Independence to recognize
that women are equal to men.
It took a civil war and the sacrifice and
the blood and gore of more than ten thousand
able-bodied youth of this country to recognize
that people of another skin color are the
same as any other skin color. Even in that
context, and given the fact that Britain took
centuries before women got the right to vote
in 1928, it was actually remarkable expression
of faith and the part of Indian Constitution
make us to recognize that all Indians, irrespective
of caste, religion, language, and we have
many, many, many languages even here. I'm
sure many people do not realize how many languages
there are in India, serious languages for
thousands of years history, hundreds of years
history, their own literature, their own script,
and their own unique culture.
[pause]
Despite all this, and despite the fact that
India was actually partitioned on the basis
of religion, the Indian Constitution make
us put enormous faith in the people of the
country. And in some respects, I think that
faith is fully vindicated.
If you take India's political evolution, it's
a remarkable success story in the sense that:
A. We retained our political freedoms. B.
There is intense electoral competition. Elections
in India are not make-believe elections. C.
The winners do not punish the losers. There
are many countries in the world where the
loser is punished merely because he lost the
election. He may lose his head or liberty
or many things. In India that never happen,
mercifully. And finally, the elected government
is truly an authority. It's not some [inaudible]
agenda.
Going by these four postulates, India is a
truly vibrant, functioning democracy. And
that we could actually maintain a moderate
rate of growth t-, in the economy and now
emerges a reasonably influential country in
terms of the future economy the globe.
It's a source of some satisfaction. But the
fact is there are also many dark corners of
Indian politics and unless they are set right,
unless we throw light on them, unless we change
that, we may not fulfill our true economic
potential.
[pause]
Particularly, because India is largely poor
and because most people are still illiterate,
because politics is in the power struggle
without any reference to ideologies or any
outcomes, because there's increasing contention
in politics, but there's only a change of
players and there's no change in the outcomes,
there's no change in the rules of the game;
money has become the currency of politics.
For those of you from the United States, it
might appear that's very normal thing in politics,
after all the US has spent a lot of money
in politics. But those are two different worlds,
altogether. The money spent here is entirely
for legitimate campaigning purposes; most
of it for television advertising. It's fully
accounted. And it's transparent. Sadly, much
of the money is spent in elections in India
is unaccounted and for illegitimate purposes,
mostly for work buying with money and liquor.
So the market economy actually works in the
politics of India. And that's what ought to
be changed. The second perversion of Indian
politics is in a country of abject poverty,
it's very easy for the governments to seduce
the workers, offering them all kinds of freebies;
unsustainable in the long term, very detrimental
to public good, but in the short term there's
always a way of persuading the worker that
they're free power, free color television,
free rice, and every month some amount of
money, irrespective of everything else that
that will be given once the government resumes
office.
I'm not mention this things as casual. These
are all a real sore spot in India by political
parties; some of them actually were delivered.
There is state of time in order where every
family was offered a color television. And
they were actually delivered in significant
measure. I don't know how many were delivered
finally, but millions of color televisions
were delivered by the elected government as
part of the promise that they made to the
electorate befor election. So increasingly,
parties resort to this kind of thing; taking
advantage of the poverty. The third is, of
course, in a very diverse country with many
primordial loyalties, it's very easy to divide
the people in caste, region, religion, and
language. And mobilize them as working blocks,
with orders and stuff, "What's in it for me
if I work for this party or that party?" Because
there's no, there's no sense that any party
would make any difference, therefore, there's
only emotional purchase available.
Once we have these three attitudes in politics,
which are increasingly dominant in the mainstream
political parties, we have seen this crisis.
We have elections, we help peaceful transfer
of power, we have fierce contention, we have
liberty, but political outcomes are simply
not what India needs and that's what ought
to be changed.
And therefore, my argument is that this kind
of a 19th-century political mode, a medieval
political mode where politics is all about
power struggle, when we master the art of
getting into power without bothering about
the outcomes, that cannot be coexist in the
21st-century economy. One of them has to give
in. Either the politics must change, or the
economy will eventually decline and collapse.
What will happen depends on what we do in
the next ten years or so in India.
A comparison with China would be very apt
because many people, obviously, are interested
in the two Asian giants in terms of population
we're now more number two, respectively. In
terms of growth based upon large economies,
now China is number one and India is pretty
close to being number two. And in terms of
potential, India could well emerge as one
of the economic giants of the world in the
next 30 years if we do well.
So obviously, comparisons are inevitable.
But I think one, one has to understand things
in perspective. One argument often advanced
is that China is not a democracy; therefore,
they can do pretty much what they want.
And therefore, they can actually focus on
excellence in economic growth even at the
cost of short term political price. Because
after all, one of the great challenges of
democratic politics anywhere in the world
is the conflict between the short term political
price you have to pay for pursuing right policies,
and the long term, slow rate of social payoff
is one of the most difficult things anywhere
in the world.
That's why we all love to hate politicians,
because politicians are present with this
all the time. They have to reconcile confronting
interests and satisfy all groups, and they
have to be mindful of the short term political
price and yet focus on the long term public
good. These are awesome challenges. Obviously,
in a dictatorship you don't have this problems;
it's easier.
Nevertheless, I think we're always taken the
case when we try and say that democracy is
detrimental to economic growth. I would like
to argue that almost everything good that
happen in China is actually because of the
democratization of society. And almost everything
bad that happen in China after the October
rev-, 1948 revolution was because Chinese
leadership on occasion acted autocratically
in an arbitrary manner.
Take the later case, The Great Leap Forward,
between 1959 and '62, because of Mao Zedong's
actually irrational policies, arbitrary policies,
20 million Chinese starved to death. 1959
to '62 was not because of
[pause]
any sensible policies. The autocracy of China
actually caused perhaps the greatest man-made
misery in the 20th century. Similarly, the
Cultural Revolution of the 1960s, it was again
another initial blunder. But the good things
that happened in China are because they tried
to democratize: education, healthcare access,
decentralization of power, technology to villages,
enhancing productivity; these are all clues
of democratization. An authoritarian leadership
actually enhanced the contingent democracy.
We always think in terms of democracy as merely
working. Democracy is more than that. We have
in India great liberty, but are we a democratic
society fully in some respects? I suspect
not. In some respects, I dare to argue that
China is perhaps more democratic than India.
You take the local governments in China. They
are far more influential.
There's far greater decentralization of power.
There is greater citizen empowerment at the
local level then in India today. Everything
in India revolves on the Prime Minister, the
Chief Minister at the provincial level and
the District Magistrate at the district level.
The citizens and the communities and the local
governments have hardly any role at all. Similarly,
education, healthcare, there's sense of a
modern democracy, have not been given the
kind of importance that they deserved in India.
What I'm arguing is the normative democracy
in terms of constitution and elections are
necessary, but not sufficient. We have to
actually have a functioning democracy in terms
of society being democratized. In terms of
fu-, people's future being decided not by
the accident of birth, accident of the womb,
but by their hard work.
And the society must give an opportunity to
fulfill her true potential. In that sense,
we have a lot to learn from China. This categorization,
crude categorization of something is a democracy,
something is not, bears immediate uncertain
indicators is not sufficient. And India must
learn with humility the art of democratization
for a society. If that is the case, what are
the things India should do? I'll come to the
concluding part of my presentation so we can
have some time for meaningful interaction.
Well, I'm making a controversial point. I'm
well aware of that and I think it requires
some serious examination.
First is local governments. One great thing
that happened in India is a maturation of
federalization. India is a multi-lingual country.
In a northern neighborhood in Canada, I've
told there's only one other language apart
from English spoken by the Quebec people,
the French language. And yet, every five years
or so, there is a demand for cessation and
there's some kind of accommodation for the
time being and we never know when Canada is
going to break up. You see a tiny country
like Belgium, for instance, again two languages
and every other day there's a fight breaking
out. Right now I'm told that there's no government
in office there. They're figuring out who
should be the Prime Minister.
You see Sri Lanka, our own southern neighbor,
there's only one other language, Sinhalese,
the main language of the country. And the
minority, northern Tamil's, they spoke the
Tamil language. And because the country did
not know how to reconcile the linguistic aspirations
of these two groups, there was a bloody civil
war, tens of thousands of people died, one
of the most murderous terrorist groups was
on rampage for decades, and only recently
they have been able to overcome the terrorist
group and hopefully, they'll learn the lesson.
And now the indications are that they are
trying to follow the Indian model of federalism.
And India, in contrast, there are at least
18 major languages. It's not like China where
Mandarin is spoken by an estimated 85% of
the people. And all the other ethnic nationalities,
apart from Han Chinese, there are only 15%
of the people. In India, the largest language
is spoken only by about 40% people, 40 to
45% people, Hindi.
In that again, there are so many dialects
that Brij Puri is different from the chaste
Hindi for let's say, Bhopal or Indore. And
other language, second biggest language, Telugu,
is spoken by about 8 to 8½% of the people.
All other languages are now after order; 8%,
6%, 5%, etc.
And yet, despite having 18 languages, each
of them with their own literature, their own
culture, their own tradition, and their own
history for centuries, some for millennia.
India could actually unite all of them if
the federalism today matured. When the Constitution
was written, while we were a federal country
it was actually quasi-federal.
The federal government was more in command
because the founding fathers were terrified
of the possibility of further vulcanization
of India, given the experience of partition
in India in 1947. But, over the past 25 years,
one of the great things that happened in India
is this federalism has now become very mature.
The states have come into their own. They
have now considerable leeway in deciding things,
and in deciding their own des-, their own
destinies.
But the tragedy is the states in turn have
not recognized the need to encourage local
communities to be self-governing. They spread
a constitutional injunction and we have huge
amendments in 1994, running into 7,700 words.
If you compare that with American Constitution,
the whole of American Constitution today some
222 years after it was written, it has some
7,400 words.
Our provisions relating to local governments
alone, they run into 7,700 words. And yet,
we created over-structured, under-powered
local governments and the bureaucracy, of
which I was a member for a long time, the
state legislatures, of which I'm a member
currently, these two have conspired to ensure
that the local governments are enfeebled.
There is absolutely no desire in India to
really empower the communities and to see
that the people who can preside over their
own destinies. Unless India recognizes the
merit of decentralization, a very complex
and lost country, we will never be able to
deliver services. Without local government
empowerment, you cannot have a linkage between
authority and accountability.
You cannot have a clear understanding in the
minds of the people between their word and
public good that results from that. And most
of all, you cannot have a link between taxes
and services rendered. And therefore, there'll
be always a reluctance to pay taxes.
In India, tax avoidance is a national sport.
I'm sure many of us dislike to pay taxes,
but in India we really elevate that to a very
high quality sport. Our tax to GDP ratio,
even today is only about 18%. That means only
18% of the GDP is collected by any government
at any level; federal, local, or state towards
taxes. Compare that with the United States,
it's about 40% in this country. Go to Europe.
Most countries have 50%. Some countries are
60%. Now we might not go to 60% or 50%, but
to actually have a decent, functioning state
of fulfilling responsibilities, the tax rates
must go higher. There must be greater tax
compliance.
That never happen as long as the bulk of the
people of India don't notice the link between
the taxes they pay and the services they get.
And therefore, they'll be always more towards
getting something in the, on co-, on the quick.
There'll be always a desire for short term
maximization. Like, "Make us some freebie;
this rice, or this free power, or this free
color TV. Because I know there's something
tangible that I get and I don't know what
else I'll get anyway. Therefore, that's all
I expect from politics and let the country
be damned." If that is to be changed, people
must see where the tax money is going and
they must understand alternative uses for
the tax money.
For all these reasons, we have to empower
the local governments. The way, for instance,
to change despite being an autocratic regime,
has actually been trying to do. The second
major change required is "rule of law". Normally,
India has an impeccable system of rule of
law.
The judiciary is independent, the Supreme
Court is pretty strong, perhaps not as strong
as the United States, but next to U-, US,
the judiciary is the strongest in the world.
We have many independent constitutional organs,
like the Election Commission, the world's
most powerful Election Commission. The election
law deciding body. And many of the organs.
But, nevertheless, the rule of law is pretty
weak.
The norms are different from the practice.
The police are entirely under the control
of the political institute in almost every
state in the country. We cannot even conceive
of a situation like what happened in Illinois
state in your country when Rod Blagojevich,
when he had tried to sell the, the Senator's
appointment for a price. He was promptly thrown
out of office, he's probably politically buried
forever, and he may even go to jail.
If you applied that standard in India, I'm
afraid it would 95% of us would be found wanting.
And unless we actually create a system where
there's a fierce, independence of the Crime
Investigation Authority, anticorruption agencies,
and independent prosecution. And speedy justice;
our justice system is independent, but it's
very, very slow and ponderous. I don't want
to go into details as to what needs, needs
to be done. There are simple, elegant answers
to that.
I, myself, as a member of the Administrative
Reforms Commission have specifically come
out with series of proposals to bring about
significant changes within the bounds of our
Constitution. So, the answers are evident.
But, we have to actually apply them so that
the culture of "VIPs", Very Important Persons,
the culture of cronyism, the culture of patronage,
the culture of those in power determining
all outcomes, even in justice system, and
even when it comes to crime investigation,
unless we change these things we're in serious
trouble.
After all, the strength of a market economy
is that the market drop rates equal of everybody.
It's a level playing field. And if the contracts
are not honored, if those in power decide
what'll happen and who the next billionaire
is going to be, and those who actual do business
in India are worried about how to enforce
the contracts, then obviously, they'll be
a serious aback to businesses. The third big
change we require is to fight corruption.
[pause]
Corruption is obviously prevalent in many
countries. The Blagojevich case shows in-,
America is no exception. But, in countries
like India, it's ubiquitous. It is universally
believed that if you want to do business in
India, you have to be corrupt. Countries like
the US have the Foreign Corrupt Practices
Act, which is now later adopted by the European
Commission. And eventually now has become
the United Nations Convention against Corruption.
Nevertheless, the fact is in many countries,
if you want to actually do serious business,
unless you please those in government or in
politics, you cannot move forward. Un-, unless
that is changed, I'm afraid any economic growth
will be stalled. If you want to contain corruption
again, the answers are self-evident. What
you have done to Rod Blagojevich in this country
must be possible for everybody in India: speedy
justice, confiscation of properties, throwing
them in jail, getting them out of politics,
those who are corrupt and creating a mechanism
for political campaign finance. We have an
excellent law on campaign finance in India
enacted in 2003. Works at the moment and I
was privileged to be a part of that, is largely
responsible for bringing about that law; it's
an excellent law.
In the United States, for instance, in the
wake of Watergate in 1970s, you brought in
the Campaign Finance Reform Law after Nixon's
resignation. But since then, for about 40
years, there's been no serious change. And
then came, for about 30-35 years, and then
came the Feingold-McCain Law, which is actually
a feeble legislation to improve the campaign
finance system. India has arguably one of
the finest campaign finance laws, except that
it has simply not been implemented. The parties
don't care about it. Ours is perhaps the only
party in India that goes by that in letter
in spirit.
Unless we make it mandatory to actually implement
that, and unless world banks exist, we are
in serious trouble. But meanwhile, we have
to address the challenges of corruption by
institutional mechanisms, by creating an independent,
strong, anti-corruption agency. And independent
prosecution by punishing swiftly and surely
the corrupt people by setting a strong example,
punitive example, and by doing several other
things that many other countries have successfully
done to curb corruption substantially.
Finally, politics is about incentive, just
like economics. If, in a poor country like
India, word-buying is what gets you to the
winning post, I suspect people will continue
to buy the words, many people will continue
to sell the words. If the buyer and seller
are happy, no law, no constitution can really
set that right. We have to change the incentives.
The Indian electoral system is a legacy of
the colonial Britain. It's not at all a rational
system. It's utterly irrational. I believe
Attlee, who was the Prime Minister of Britain
at that time, actually argued in favor of
other models like, the American presidential
system and the European proportional representation
system. But the Indians said, "No, we are
more British than all of you guys. We'll have
to pursue with your own electoral system even
if we get rid of you."
And that's actually happening today. In Britain,
except in the House of Commons, in every other
election they're going up this old-fashioned
First Past-the-Post system. In the regional
parliaments of Scotland, Northern Wales, and
Ireland, this is misproportionately based.
In local elections, it's proportionately based.
Europe and Ireland proportionally based. London
City, an electorate executive, an electorate
mayor, like now Boris Johnson is in, is the
mayor.
Utterly the first mayor in this new mode of
electionist Ken Livingston. India is the only
country that is sticking with the old-fashioned
British best Minister, First-Past-the-Post
model. It appears that Britain may actually
be changing back to the House of Commons level,
also. We all know what happened in the last
week when the two parties for the first time
after Second World War in Britain, headed
by Cameron and Nick Clegg, they all joined
forces to form a coalition government.
And eventually, in the next two, three years,
we may well see in Britain a shift to some
sort of proportionate representation. The
reason why India requires a shift is if one
word extra means victory, one word less means
defeat, in an abjectly poor country where
the political culture is already considerably
damaged, word buying is rampant. Word buying
will continue, corruption will continue, politics
will be distorted.
We have to change it to a system where if
you vote this way, that way, it don't matter,
it's the person that the votes to get. It's
not how much you control the constituency.
As a local zemindar as we call it, a local
chief, a man with complete clout, complete
domination of the local population. That's
what really gives political dividends in India
today. We have to change it to a system where
it's the major party and the candidates. And
the platform of the political party, rather
than the news offered to individuals to get
the marginal vote that will determine the
political outcomes. If we do these things,
then we could have probably change India's
political system from the 19th-century archaic
model to something approximate in the 21st
century. And our economy and our politics
can co-exist.
Einstein once said, "Twentieth century is
characterized by perfection of means and confusion
of ends." Indian politicians have mastered
the art of acquiring power. They perfected
their means. But what power is about, in terms
of outcomes, is something that eludes us all
the time. There's hardly any change in respect
of what happens, no matter who is in office.
And that's what should be changed in India.
I believe Indian people are alive to this
challenges. They are capable of addressing
them, but they require an urgent push from
all over the world with our compatriots of
Indians. Indian compatriots are there. People
of Indian origin is there, are there.
The businesses of India, all Indian businesses,
they must argue for change because they must
not think politics is different from economics.
There is a notion in business circles that
what will do business isn't related to what,
what kind of politics takes shape. Politics
has a decisive influence on the way businesses
take shape and the way economic growth trajectory
takes shape. And unless we address the larger
questions of politics without being partisan,
without really getting into who should be
in power, but focusing on what should be the
outcomes.
Unless we do that, economy itself is in peril.
Indian businesses are now slowly awakening
themselves to this reality. We require a change
fundamentally. I believe we will change. When
status quo is unsustainable, change is inevitable.
That's why the Berlin Wall fell in 1989. It
did not fall because of any bullets or warfare;
it fell because the people voted with their
feet. Because they could see the contrast
between what's happening across the borders,
across the wall, and in their own society.
And they could not take it any longer.
And no society could depress its people forever.
And a democratic society will change when
people want it adequately, but people must
be awakened to the possibilities of change.
But the danger is change will still happen;
it will not be the right kind of change. Twenty
years ago, there was a very popular story
in Moscow. I believe hundreds of people were
queuing in front of a Russian shop for a few
crumbs of bread in Moscow City, on a bitter,
biting, cold, winter morning. They waited
and waited but there was no bread in sight.
When young man lost his temper after some
time, he said, "I'm sick and tired of it.
I'll go and kill the General Secretary in
Kremlin." And they stormed off in protest.
The others still waited patiently because
they know there was still the midnight knock,
there was still the Secret Police, the Gestapo,
or whatever they called it in, in Soviet Union.
There's still the concentration camps, the
GULAGs, therefore they all waited very quietly
and patiently. The same man came back after
two hours. The others still were waiting and
there was no bread in sight. They're all gathered
around him and asked him, "What happened?
Have you killed the General Secretary?" He
said, "A riot in Kremlin can rob the store
now, children are hungry at home, please tell
us what happened?" This young man said, "You
know, I went there to kill the General Secretary,
but there was a much longer queue waiting
there."
[laughter]
This story was recounted in every single household
of Soviet Union in all the 15 republics at
the time. People laughed about it, but they
did nothing about it.
Change did come in 1991, but not the kind
of change any Soviet citizen wanted. Change
will always come. It will always overtake
us, eventually, every society. The challenge
is, is it the kind of change we all need,
we all desire and that will be positive? Or
is it the change we'll have to submit ourselves
to and pay the price for? That's the challenge
facing Indian people, and Indian politicians,
Indian civil servants, and Indian businessmen.
I believe we are all capable of rising to
the challenge and fulfilling our potential
and becoming one of the great economies on
one of the most moderating influences in the
modern world, in a complex, ever-changing,
unpredictable world. But only if we set our
house in order today. And I believe the stakes
for the world are as great as they are for
India, because what happens to one system
of humanity cannot but impact the rest of
the world. And I believe the rest of the world
is actually waiting for this, this caged lion,
to really find its own feet and find its own
direction. And I believe ultimately, 21st-century
economy and 21st-century politics will coincide
and show the way to many other countries in
emerging economies which continue to believe
that economic growth and political freedom
cannot coexist. We have to prove that these
two can and must coexist. The challenge in
that sense is fundamental and it's human.
Thank you.
[applause]
I'll be happy to take questions…comments,
criticism.
[pause]
[audience chatter]
Do we have a collar microphone? No? Ok, sorry.
>>male audience1:
[Indian accent]
Thank you very much for a great talk. I think
you said it perfectly when you said, you know,
we, we're perfect at the means but not the
ends. One of the things I find calm in Indian
politics is there is rationality, there's
no rationality in the structure. There is
a structure deficit when it comes to peace
and, for example, like take that Tamilaru
TV promise. There was no motivation to actually
say, "OK, we're promising a TV for every household,
but this is what it's gonna buy us." Or, for
example, even if you take the Supreme Court,
right? Right now the new Chief Justice came
up and, I mean, like, he took office, first
day in 29 minutes he cleared five cases by
simply dismissing most of them.
[JP laughs]
And, the thing is, I mean, all these things
are quite arbitrary. And the reason why that
is, is before somebody like, any official,
any, any organization, anybody, does something,
there is no requirement or motivation to say
why they are doing it, what is the purpose,
what is, what is the measurable goal they
are trying to achieve? Any of that. I wonder
if you could, if you could, you know, speculate
on what could be done to, for more of that
kind of--
>>JP:
It's, it's a good question. I'll address each
of this briefly so that we get a sense of
what it's about. Take the Supreme Court. Normatively,
the Supreme Court is supposed to function
like the American Supreme Court. But we bungle
even in the initial stages, to be fair. Instead
of making it a constitutional code, which
it ought to be in a very large, federal country,
we made also an appellate court and practically
everything under the sun.
And also we gave it original jurisdiction
on certain issues. The naturalities, in the
United States, you know, Supreme Court, typically
100 to 150 cases, I may be, I may be wrong
by an order of magnitude of ten, twenty percent.
Only that many cases are taken every year.
And they're heard continuously by all the
nine Justices. And at the end of the year
if there is some pretty big cases never heard,
they're all set aside because they'll come,
they'll come another day. A constitutional
court doesn't have to see everything under
the sun.
Whereas in India, typically every year we
have tens of thousands of cases going before
the courts and of course have to be really,
are very arbitrary as a set. Suppose we create
very much like in the US federal courts of
appeal, for appeals over the high court judgments
at the state level, and then have the Supreme
Court only as the Constitutional Court that
is basically envisaged, then the problem would
be substantially addressed.
>>audience1:
Right.
>>JP: So there are very simple answers. In
fact, K. K. Venugopal, a very distinguished
advocate and jurist, has very strongly argued
for this recently in a, in a brilliant two,
two piece article in The Hindu and I complimented
N.Ram, the editor for The Hindu, for actually
raising the debate and I believe we have to
look at these issues.
Look at politics, there are two fundamental
schisms. One is the role of the state; we
haven't yet really addressed it as a society
whether distributing television sets is the
function of a government. Or is it related
to this rule of law and there's education
and health care of reasonable quality. What
is the function of a government? We haven't
yet come down to it. If it's more like a Maharajadhiraja,
a king, a monarch, doing pretty much what
she or he wanted.
The second is, within the government is structure
again, the role of a particular tier of government,
an organ of state is very unclear in the minds
of politicians and the public themselves.
So the notion what is federal, or what does
the federal government do, what does the state
do, what does the local government do, what
does judicial do, what do the police do, what
does bureaucracy do, what does legislature
do, what does executor do? There simply blurred
lines, therefore, most people expect a legislator
to behave like an executor, and an executor
to be actively important and vestful. Judiciary
actually wants to be all the time to be the
executor, sometimes even the lawmaker.
All kinds of things are happening. Distortions
are there. And when it come to the people,
at the end of the day, in a system where the
word has no meaningful consequence in their
lives, and this is a central fact, and in
a system where a few words more or less is
gonna determine the political outcomes, in
an abjectly poor country what happened is
a very natural thing. What's happening in
India in terms of money politics is a rational
response to an irrational situation. It's
a perfect irrational response. I mean, if
I were a citizen, if I know that nothing probably
of any consequence happen in terms of the
outcome in the election, then I would try
to maximize my short term gain.
>>audience1:
Right.
>>JP:
And if a thousand rupees or two thousand pieces
offered per vote, and this not an ab-, this
is not an abstract figure, it's a very real
figure in India in several states, particularly
Andhra Pradesh, Tamil Nadu, Karnataka, etc.
In an abjectly poor country there's big money.
And therefore, I try to maximize my short
term gain. Others, the freebies after the
election, the free power and free color TV.
Or emotional purchase because in a primordial
society, where caste and other loyalties are
all important, and we haven't really enabled
people to discover that there's something
more important than your caste, there's something
personal for your family. Better education
for your children, maybe. Good health care
for your family, maybe. That's more important
than your caste and religion. Unless we establish
that link, always this primordial loyalties
be more important.
And therefore, emotional purchase. And politicians
are perfect at the art of using these three
purchases: directly buying the vote, offering
freebies for the vote, or giving emotional
purchase in the form of caste, religion, and
language. And that's why we have to address
in these three vests, local governments, citizen
central governments, electoral system, a fight
against corruption. It can't be a one sector,
one [inaudible], there's no single silver
bullet. I will say these are the five bullets
together.
>>audience1:
Right.
>>JP:
And unless we are understand adequately, I
know all of the deeply concerned, but unless
the concern is informed by a deep awareness
of what, what's the way forward, it could
be a really concern. We have to actually go
forward. And that's my argument.
>>audience1:
Thank you.
>>JP:
Thank you. I'll try and be brief, I know.
>>male audience2:
[Indian accent]
Yes.
>>JP:
Please.
>>audience2:
So, most of the problems that you mentioned
revolve around two causes. Basically, there
isn't probably a right re-, legalization of
probably like, procedure for it, like you
mentioned the Supreme Court thing, right?
Like, that we don't have a like, a separate
appeals court, right? And the second one you
mentioned was there is no right implementation
in, in spite of the right legalization existing,
but the people we expect them to correct are
the same people who are getting the purchase
out of it by exploiting it. So, it's, it's,
it's like a loop it seems to me, like, h-,
how, how do you resolve that--
>>JP: It's a terrific question. It's a terrific
question. In our politics, it's about solving
the dilemmas of a society. If you have a constitution
whose intent is sound, politics is the structure,
the bridge between the constitutional values
and the society's current culture. Now, if
politics that ought to be a solution has become
part of the problem, then we turn to the vicious
cycle. The dangerous loop you talked about.
But let's go a little backwards. Why did this
happen in the first place?
When India became free, we had arguably, the
greatest galaxy of leaders ever assembled
on the face of the earth. The only comparison
would be to the American Freedom Fighters
and the Constitution makers, the Founding
Fathers of the United States. There is no
other episode in history when such a galaxy
of liberal-minded, well-educated, deeply committed,
great leaders came together with a common
purpose to build a nation. Post-independence
was some time again, that caste played a role.
But subsequently, the best and the brightest
society. They have given up on politics. They
have thought that they would pursue their
own personal goals, which is of total their
right, that's what life is about, but at the
cost of public domain. The vacuum is left
and the scum of humanity increasingly filled
that. Or bad practices particularly took over.
In politics, too, like in economics, aggression's
law operates. Bad politics always drives away
good politics. So, the answer really lies,
in order to break this deadlock, this logjam,
in the middle classes, the educated people,
the young people who are forward looking recognize
in the centrality of politics even to the
economic future of the country. And playing
a role.
Everyone doesn't have to simply give up everything
and then go and become a martyr or a farmer.
Everybody can't go and become a contestant.
But we all have to play creative political
roles as citizens from registration from voting
to voting sensibly and definitely to mobilizing
other people to think rationally, to pursuing
rational policies, to enhancing the quality
of public discourse, to everything that's
required to really make a democracy healthy.
Look at the United States the way there was
this massive debate in this country in the
healthcare policies. And even truly perhaps
the last word has not said. And there's going
to be an election in the next few months and
maybe people will have a chance to speak,
speak up. And, I'm, I'm sure there'll be a
sequel to that. That is the stuff of politics.
In India, I don't recall, I'm not sure if
I can recall a single instance when a Prime
Minister ever addressed the country on a single
issue of say, how to educate our people? How
to improve the quality of healthcare? Or anything
else for that matter.
So we have to redefine politics and unless
the middle classes are deeply engaged, and
unless they learn the art of pursuit of personal
goals along with pursuit of public good simultaneously,
we have problem. Somewhere we have to break
this logjam. Politicians, there's no point
blaming them, I know we all love to hate politicians.
Everybody, even in the United States, everybody
loves to hate a Congressman or politician.
It's a normal, democratic skepticism. It's
a good, healthy thing. But that doesn't solve
the problem. You can improve politics only
by better politics and more politics, not
by abolition of politics.
>>audience2:
Thank you.
>>male audience3:
[Indian accent]
Dr. JP, thank you for coming here. You said
politics are intertwined with money, not only
that, in India they're also intertwined with
violence. So, maybe there should have been
a competition of ideas. It's been, it's been
replaced, it's already is replaced by competition
of rhetoric. So, what I wanted to ask you
was about a specific instance. How do you
think the Telangana issue should be handled
and what is your party's stance on that?
>>JP:
Ok, I knew this question would come up in
some form or the other.
[laughter]
And I'm sure another question will come up
about reservations; I'll be surprised if it
doesn't come up. You know, we love polarities
in India. We love a yes or no kind of an approach.
But we have to be a little more sensible and
practical about dealing with this matters.
As I said before, our federalism has matured
remarkably. One of the great success stories
of India is of federalism. In the past 25
years, there's been a steep change in federalism;
we can be very, justly proud of that. It's
the only great example of a truly diverse
society that models federalism after the United
States.
In some ways a much more miraculously than
the United States because we have such vast
linguistic gulf, apart from poverty, etc.
But nevertheless, in a complex federal policy,
we're going to have these issues coming up.
But, we must not lose our shirt over that
and this whole notion that creation of a Telangana
is a disaster, or it is a solution; it is
a cure.
Both is very dangerous. It's neither a cure
nor a catastrophe. We must take it in our
stride. Except practical, political arrangements
and people are seeking. Now, how practical
is it? Is it the best way forward, is something
that the nation must slowly debate and come
to terms with it because the, the implications
are not going to be merely regional or limited
to one state. They are going to apply to the
whole country. If language is not a marker,
in a country where every non-Hindi state has
one state, one language principle, work with
a new marker so that in, in Tamil Nadu, the
Northern part of the country, the Eastern
or Western part of the country, demands now
crop up, how we deal with that will depend
on what kind of markers we decide.
There's nothing wrong in having markers. Like
an artisan in some parts, you can simply say,
"I'll take this parallel and I'll take this
vertical, and that's it. I don't care how
this state is created, but this is my state."
There's nothing wrong with that, that's what
India wants. But you must also uniform principle.
The second thing is the first part of India
where a region, which is host to the Capital
City, unlike in United States, the capitalist
in India not only politically centralized,
but also economically centralized, demographically
centralized. The hubs of economic growth,
that region in all seem to have a separate
statehood. Until now, it's the far flung regions
heavy from big cities that wanted a separate
statehood. Now when economy is increasingly
concentrated around big cities, what is every
interest at? Because what happens here could
happen tomorrow in Western Maharashtra Mumbai.
Northern Tamil Nadu in Chennai, Southern Karnataka
in Bangalore, or some other state with some
other capital city, or big city.
We're to realize, we have to recognize that
there is an issue here and find a way of resolving
that issue. Once we do those two things, it
doesn't matter what we do. We can, because
it makes no difference. The real answer lies
in local governments, not in one state more
or one state less. Neither integration nor
separation of a state is going to change anything
monumentally. It's just going to create one
more Chief Minister in the Cabinet. Nothing
more.
>>audience3:
Thank you.
>>JP:
Yeah.
>>male audience4:
[Indian accent]
Since I'm the last question, I'd like to ask
two questions, ok?
[JP laughs]
My first question is about the distinction
that you drew about the Chinese ground level
democracy versus our normative, the normative
democracy in India. I read a book by Fareed
Zakaria where he kind of drew a distinction
between democracy and rule of law. And he
said that rule of law is equally or more important
than actually elections and other external
characteristics of democracy. But I don't
think that rule of law actually exists at
ground level in China either, they don't have
even the property rights, even though they're
not strong in India, they're probably stronger
in India than China. So I would like to have
your thoughts about why does --
>>JP:
OK
>>audience4:
work in China? That's question number one.
Question number two is about the Maoist Insurgents
in India. Even people like [inaudible] are
coming out saying that because of this abject
failure of governments and there even the
Maoists are out there; violence might be the
only answer that the people there might have
against the Indians--
>>JP:
Good questions, but--
>>audience4:
I don't, I don't agree with him, I just want
your thoughts--
>>JP:
I understand. First about Fareed Zakaria and
China's rule of law and absence of it. Now,
when I made a comparison between India and
China, I did just to caution the Indian scholars
and others who consistently argue that we
are so democratic and wonderful that we have
nothing to change. It is not to argue that
China is better than India in that respect.
That would be a foolish argument.
All I'm arguing is that there are factions
in Chinese governance which are perhaps more
democratic than in a liberal, free Indian
society. Overcentralization has been our bane.
Decentralization has been their strength.
Decentralization by definition is democratization.
A total democratization. In India, we have
not yet done it.
Obviously, rule of law is far more deficient
in China than in India. In India, the instruments
of rule of law are really very strong; they're
there. The delivery is weak for a variety
of reasons we have to now set that right.
But in other ways, the acceptance of rule
of law as a notion, as a norm, are the instruments
of rule of law a constitutional and legal
instruments of rule of law, we are ages ahead
of China. There's no question, but still we
have to set something straight.
Obviously, what we have to demonstrate to
the world is that freedom and economic growth
are compatible. Democracy is not related to
growth because some people are now coming
to the dangerous conclusion that growth in
an emerging economy means autocracy. So why
I argue, so why I'm arguing that China is
invested democratic is, is democratic impulses
of China that actually led to growth, not
autocratic impulses. You must see both of
them together.
Otherwise, I agree. But I'm not very, a great
fan of the notion of Fareeh Zakaria, that
you must increasingly view power to the unelected.
I recognize the importance of the unelected
institutions like the Supreme Court, like
the Election Commission, etc. But the think
that you can somehow solve the problems of
politics by nonpolitical institutions is a
typical bureaucratic or middle class approach.
There is no substitute to politics. Clean,
decent politics, mobilizing public opinion,
and more and more and better and better people
playing a creative role; being deeply engaged
as citizens and as, as people who would influence
the outcomes of the local level and the state
and national level. There's no substitute
to that. And the danger is, and somehow believing
that because we have a Supreme Court, we have
an Election Commission, or some other strong
body, everything will be alright. My friend,
Seshan, a very good personal friend, even
today, and since has very few friends remaining
actually, he's a good man but not very strong
and sometimes a civic man. He was a great
Election Commissioner. What did he prove?
He proved that the constitutional lawist in
India could be autonomous if they really,
sought, sought to be so. If they chose to
be so. He proved that they could actually
be independent. But, could he change the nature
of elections in India? Far from it. Seshan
himself knows that. It's not his failure.
After all, the constitution itself is a creation
of the constitution and a law of the land.
The Parliament gives the mandate for the Election
Commission to function. It can only function
within that. It has no mandate to go beyond
that. Therefore, to think that somehow by
investing so much authority and prestige and
hope in them, we can solve the problems of
India, we'd comitting a great mistake. They
are necessary, but they're not sufficient.
Ultimately, politics have to be set by politics.
About Maoists, I'm glad you asked this question.
Undoubtedly, the failure of governance in
India are in capacity to fulfill the aspirations
of the bulk of the people. And the fact that
the accident of birth is determined in the
future by the bulk of the children. These
are the fuel; these are the fodder for generating
any number of violent moments. Some of them
turned to be Maoist; that's not the only one.
We have recognized that, but having recognized
that if we do not also recognize that in a
democratic society where the constitutional
liberty are available and vote is available,
the only forum of dissent, form of dissent
is within the bounds of the constitution.
Namely, you holler, you shout, you protest,
you demonstrate without obstructing others,
without disrupting other peoples freedoms,
in front of the White House. When I went the
other day, I saw; found two groups of people
with the banners about all kinds of things.
That is legitimate democratic protest, its
basis is provided and they continue to try
and attract public attention and eventually,
as even politicians recognize that they cannot
ignore that issue, they will address that.
That is democracy. All else should feel sufficiently
mad about it, like some of the nice Hollywood
films. Somebody gets into Congress and moves
the Congress and the nation and something
about it. That's all politics is about. But
if I say that because I'm not happy with the
way things are, I will take to the gun, I
will extinguish the liberties available under
the Constitution, I'll take law into my hands,
and I will, in fact, repeal this constitution
instead of abolish the constitution itself.
That's not acceptable. Therefore, the state
and the people have every right and duty to
do everything within the bounds of the constitution
to control it. Let there be no mistake, whatsoever.
Abraham Lincoln had this question repeatedly
posed to him during the Civil War. He said
time and again if the first article of the
American Constitution collapses, all else
fails.
Therefore, in order to preserve the first
article, namely the union, there should be
union of states. I will do whatever it takes.
Just like there is a hierarchy of principles
or hierarchy of needs, there is also a hierarchy
of principles. The ultimate principle for
the state is to preserve the Constitutional
order. Everything else is to become subordinate
to that. Having said that, merely by doing
whatever it takes to control them is it enough?
No. We also have to create a just order, give
confidence to the bulk of the people that,
"Look, we understand your agony. We hear your
voice, we created a framework which more just
and more humane and it's not even perfect,
it's always work in progress, but everybody
has a chance." I don't agree with, the author
at all in this respect. I know, you don't
either. It's very dangerous not to use arguments
without understanding the context. She's able
to speak out because she's at liberty.
What happened in Cambodia, please remember.
When Pol Pot was in power, one third of all
Cambodian people were decimated. The youngest
child was first killed so that the rest of
the family understood the pain. The fellow
with glasses, somebody like you or me, just
because you wore glasses, the fact that you
wore glasses means that you are, you are not
a hard working man. You're not a liberal.
They feel you are dangerous to society. They
killed them. The people with soft hands; they
were killed. One after the whole family was
killed. One third of the whole country was
butchered by its own government. It never
happened in history, not even Hitler did that.
If that is how a notion of a future, I don't
think any Indian wants it. Because of temporary
anger about the injustices on occasion we
may say, "Oh, next race is better." But no.
It's a dangerous argument. As long as freedom
is there, as long as vote is there, there's
only one route, there's, there's only one
road.
That man may not be recorded but they have
some questions I'll be happy to take. It's
up to you.
Ok, ok, ok. I'll just take that question.
>>male audience5:
[Indian accent]
You recently become the MLA in, in some region.
So, I'd like to know some of the positive
experiences you had in like, typical Indian
movies and Indian literature, the recent one.
They depict Indian politics as something really
nasty, something really dirty. Actually, you've
met some people at some, at least civilians
who were nice to you, who actually abided
by the line, give you a kind of positive spirit
like, "Yes, there are people who want a change."
I'd like to know more about that.
>>JP:
Ok. First of all, we must have a, a broader
argument. Are politicians necessarily scoundrels?
Does it mean that the scum of humanity in
this politics and all the nice people and
nice people are outside politics? Are there
two groups of society? Or, are politicians
doing, in a set of circumstances, whatever
they think they should do in order to try?
We must have some clarity. I would plead with
you to recognize that politicians are just
another set of human beings.
They are not a very specialized set of corrupt,
rotten, criminal human beings, they are human
beings. Period. If you create an institutional
framework where by doing what is right you
can also politically prosper, they would happily
do that. The Prime Ministers, the Chief Ministers,
the MPs and MLAs of India, they are not taking
a vow to destroy India. They are taking a
vow to do whatever it takes to get, to get
into power. And to do whatever it takes to
stay in power. It's for us to create a system
where you can do something honorable and decent
and public-spirited and yet, be politically
relevant.
If you consistently prove that by doing the
nice thing and the right thing, you're politically
irrelevant. We are actually driving them to
do something wrong. My experience proved this
to be absolutely true. Most of the fellow
legislators of my, in my provincial assembly,
80% of them at least, almost everybody, with
exception of myself, they have paid money
to get the vote. It's, it's universally known.
But despite that, they recognize that they
have become victims of a vicious cycle. Given
a choice, given a chance, they'll actually
do something nice and decent. They despair
all the time, but they feel that they are
in the vicious cycle they can't get out of
the trap easily. So, they're not villains.
And my faith is vindicated. But, will they
always behave in a manner that, that really
oppose their views? No. Because they're creatures
of their own parties, they're slaves of their
party, and they're slaves of the power game.
And they simply feel that there's no escape
from that.
So, unless there is external pressure and
pull, and unless we, we mobilize the society
and prove that clean politics and honesty
are compatible with survival in our public
office; I don't think we can change that.
I'll conclude the comment with one last word.
We have in India today a phenomenal opportunity.
We have the technology, thanks to all of you,
the world is virtually flat, and we can access
almost everything that's happening almost
anywhere in the world; get knowledge of a
kind which would be unbelievable earlier.
We have the resources, may not be enough to
have an American standard of living, which
probably is crazy anyway. It's too high. It's
not possible for the whole globe, but we have
enough resources to be able to fulfill all
the basic needs of Indian people and to give
opportunity for us to fulfill our potential
as a country.
What we lack are institutions. What we lack
is the right kind of politics. And with all
these institutions, technology plant, can
be transplanted easily. Institutions like
take a lot of nurturing. Institutions take
a lot of public pressure. Institutions take
the middle classes and the educated people
to be engaged; deeply and on a sustained basis.
What I'm arguing is, let us be engaged because
our future is on the line. And in a fundamental
sense, the mankind's truthfulness is on the
line. There's no reason for cynicism and despair
at all. On occasion it appears to be exceedingly
difficult, but there are forces of change.
The young people are increasingly more confident,
they believe that they can change their country;
they're idealistic whether they live in India
or abroad. Economic growth itself is actually
spurring forces of change in the country.
It's going to make many people ask uncomfortable
questions and the communications evolution
that all of you have had is reaching in you
also, many Indians, including the ordinary,
poor, shop owners, and, and hard workers.
And all these will ultimately bring about
a fundamental change, but the question is
what direction of change it'll take? That
depends on what we do now. That's why I gave
you the most great example. If we do the right
thing together, today, if we give confidence,
then that change will be the right one. Otherwise,
change will anyway happen, but not the, not
necessarily the right one. I ask a few in
our own enlightened self-interest, interest
of India, and in a larger sense an interest
with the broader humanity. We worked ourselves
to make a difference to the way the Indian
political trajectory takes shape. Thank you
very much.
[applause]